my name is lambrecht chu I'm going to be
for my your project I'm going to be
building a class recommendation system
for MIT undergraduate students so as you
know there's a lot of interesting
classes to choose from MIT students
often have a hard time deciding which
one to choose from and right now there's
no great system for helping to recommend
which classes that tape so as a result
i'm going to be building in a web
application for students to use so our
my application will take into account
the students major the classes that he
or she has taken so far as well the
students interests in what kind of
subjects they like so in the past
there's been a lot of collaborative
learning algorithms out there already
they take into account the decisions of
similar users to recommend things to our
current users so for example I'm going
to be doing something that Amazon does
which is items I and palabra filtering
based on what items a person has bought
they will recommend other items that are
similar to it so that's kind of the same
way analogous to classes so that's one
approach I'm taking another way of doing
it is to calculate the importance of
each class so we find the number of
students that is taken each pair of
classes and based on the history of
class of students taking so far too
recommends the ones that have the
greatest overlap and also plan on
incorporating an element of natural
language processing so I'm a student can
enter in these are her interest in there
and then for example the type in machine
learning and that would increase the
importance of the recommendations for
classes that involve machine learning
such as 6036 or six or three four